yeah it does feel like forever since
i've reviewed an animated family film
but i'll say this if more animated
family films played sabotage by the
beastie boys in the trailer i'd be
reviewing more animated family films
so minions the rise of gru is another
minions movie slash despicable me movie
it's another despicable me prequel or a
minion sequel however you want to see it
basically you have the minions adventure
and you have gru well little kid grew
anyway hanging out with his childhood
hero who's really his childhood villain
voiced by alan arkin and they're on
their adventure and in that i actually
thought it did remarkably well in
dividing the workload among the two
stories and among the two character
groups anyway and i will lie to you i've
come to actually appreciate the minions
just as characters as as what they are i
mean when i look back i feel like
they're kind of like the goblins of
labyrinth but for this generation though
to be fair the goblins from labyrinth
should be the goblins from labyrinth in
every generation that's a timeless film
just i appreciate the fact that the
minions are the sanguine psychos of this
generation i think kids need that in a
world where everyone's telling kids like
fred in this box you must be this way i
like the fact that there are characters
out there that are like and it's fine to
be chaotic too nurtures imagination did
for me anyway maybe i'm projecting but i
will say despicable me movies going
forward henceforth from here on should
be young gru and this super villain
voiced by alan arkin just steve carell
and alan arkin
how could that not sell if they did that
from here on out and those were
despicable me movies i would totally be
down because it does have that flavor of
despicable me you know despicable me was
this super villain who has these kids
now and you know there's this parental
element in there it's very sweet very
nice so i hear i'm a cold-hearted
bachelor so you know the people i know
with kids they were like trust me on
this it was very nice but given the two
concepts of a super villain who's
already a super villain and then he
finds his kids and he learns to be a
parent or this young child psychopath
who's aspiring to be a super villain and
he's hanging out with his hero super
villain and they still have that you
know the surrogate father parental
dynamic little kid grew is it man that's
goldilocks zone that's prime grew right
there now surprisingly fun as this movie
was for me it does run into that thing
where it's it tries to do too much it
tries to be the master of all things but
really it's the master of none i mean
it's fine in what it sets out to do for
its purpose but it has story lines that
they either should have cut from the
movie or dedicated far more time to then
the end of the movie runs into the thing
where you ever play a video game there's
a three-phase boss fight and by the end
of the boss fight by the third phase
you're like it's not even that character
anymore you're just fighting a big
monster this movie does that so i never
felt like there was a showdown with the
villains of the movie but i feel all
that might come secondary to the fact
that the kids in the auditorium were
going crazy for this movie and for me
that's the biggest metric right there
you know it's a lot of screenings are
just us you know us who review movies
critics reviewers whatever you want to
say everyone has their notepads out
ready to go to war with this film
nitpick everything it was literally an
auditorium full of families and children
they loved it so i can definitely say if
you have kids they will probably have a
good time in this movie like the
despicable me movies for me or the
minions movies whatever they are it's
like some i've enjoyed more than others
but regardless they all have this one
thing in common and for some odd reason
i don't know why it's just how my brain
is programmed for them by the time the
next movie comes out i will have
forgotten all about the previous movie i
don't know why it's just like the next
movie movie's coming out my brain's like
oh we were supposed to hold on to that
i'd i'd hit control alt delete
we just kind of made room for other
stuff if you don't know what that's like
give it a couple decades you will and
despicable me it's just one of those
properties that's just how i am with
them but i will say i had fun with this
movie and i hope i hold on to the memory
of that was it perfect no not at all it
was even sloppy in parts but i did have
a couple chuckles i was afraid it would
be all little kid antics in the way that
it would speak to little kids but
parents would be like all right i'm
really bored but there were some jokes
in there i got a good chuckle out of i
was like kids aren't gonna understand
what that is that was for the adults and
i appreciate that if you're looking for
a fun family movie night out this
weekend you could do far worse than this
one the movie's 90 minutes long which i
appreciate right there right in the
pocket right where you want a movie like
this to be in the end i just i walked
out having a good time no alcohol
required all right so minions the rise
of gru have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you